Angelina Jolie is seemingly ready to end  her ongoing custody battle with Brad  Pitt there's not a lot of sleep Joe  Lee's lawyer filed a new Court docs  saying the actress agrees the pair's  court case should be kept confidential  but if their six kids have been damaged  by their public splint the actress  claims is all on Brad according to the  legal docs filed by her attorney Laura  wiser Brad is quote terrified that the  public will learn the truth there's many  things that can go wrong a source close  to Brad tells et he quote has been  cleared after thorough investigations by  both FBI and Child Services which  included Angelina Jolie's cooperation  clearly her claims were considered  legitimate enough to impact those  conclusions but another source tells et  while his behavior didn't amount to  anything criminal the kids are clearly  traumatized and Angelina has been  protecting the kids by not revealing  what really happened on the plane